quand je vois autour de moi les gens qui
quand je vois les gens autour de moi qui
commence à voir des enfants donc je
pense à mon père quand j'étais petit je
me dis les papas ils sont quand même
tous très différents
un vrai papa par définition ça l'art et
la manière de te [ __ ] la honte
mon papa comme d'habitude un qui me
dépasse 30 mètres avant le collage
bayonne fiston j'ai ton âge j'ai ce que
c'est allez fils ça vaut quoi saoudite -
bonne journée mon petit fils ton papa te
fais un bisou en wifi quand je pense que
tu puisses eolys que tu es 12 ans allez
ciao
le beau gosse du collège c'est un
printemps ce volontaire j'ai le droit
d'avoir un poids de 45 ans ça y est moi
mon père et internet
c'est vraiment pas l'amour fou on n'est
pas sur une fusion non mais il est
mignon info il m'a souhaité bonne
anniversaire sur facebook mais sur la
photo d'un autre mec que je connais pas
je sais même pas comment il a fait même
mark zuckerberg sait pas comment il a
fait
les papas ils font des vrais trucs de
papa par exemple clipser leur portable à
la ceinture
[Musique]
aux appels manqués pourquoi il
rappellera les pères ils ont vraiment
des demandes spéciales papa zoé tu peux
mettre la police en engrange voit rien
du tout ouais t'as pas c'est au maximum
la haye l'a lu et lol un vrai faire tu
vois ça un instinct vrai instinct de
papa notamment pour détecter certaines
choses matteo tu fais quoi là rien
pourquoi ronge tout de suite et de
cigarettes dont le paquet de kamel light
et que tu es dans la main gauche s'il te
plaît ok ce mec c'est cancérigène papa
m'aime pas que tu fumes ces saloperies
un vrai papa c'est important parce que
ça nous apprend des choses que personne
d'autre pourrait nous apprendre tu vois
tu vois xavier les votes truc d'hommes
ne s'apprend pas ça se refilent de père
en fils
aujourd'hui je te montrer comment on
fait pour réparer un moteur de voiture
cool on commence par quoi
le match commence par rappeler un
garagiste a tout simplement et après je
te montrerai comment on fait pour
cuisiner comme papa des bonnes petites
margarita c'est que le père parfois il
est un peu le rôle du parent autoritaire
un temps incertain l'éducation parfois
importants on mettre un petit coup de
collier clémentine maintenant tu fais
tes devoirs et je comprends rien si les
noirs bon tu prêtait de voir demain
mais demain tu les fais bien ça commence
à suffire parfois ton père il a beau
avoir 45 ans sais pas pourquoi tout à
coup ils se croient à nouveau jeunes
comme angers qui fut son dernier clip
elle trouve ça lui dit jones
alors on zone j'espère que vous prenez
pas de la gaudreault papa tu peux sortir
de ma chambre je te plaît allez venez on
peut juste une petite dogfights pour mon
snow pitch est papa allez quoi juste
pour caudry ont fait une fine ou alors
ils essayent un peu de revivre sa
jeunesse à travers toi c'est qu'il ya
plein de pères qui veulent absolument
que leur fils leur ressemble mais papa
tu avais dit qu'on venait d'avoir des
animaux au zoo écoute didier on doit
aller à bricorama faire du bricolage
comme des hommes ok j'ai eu huit ans je
m'en fous de rigoler on ne négocie pas
didier hiel réseau cette barbe la même
pas trop hein
tout ça parce que tu es jaloux c'est ça
toi y'a que la moustache qui pousse
depuis que tenait
alors là tu vas trop loin dg sera privé
de dessert didier n'a pas de but didier
didier parfois les papas sous leurs airs
de gentil père de famille ils ressentent
le besoin nous prouver qu'ils sont quand
même encore un peu rebelle et a pas le
feu orange à toi que ton père est pas
capable de passer à l'orangé
alors on prend toujours son père pour
une [ __ ]
bonjour appelé du véhicule s'il vous
plaît ne me fais jamais ça
les papas en général je dis bien en
général ils savent faire la cuisine mais
ça faire un plat 1 c'est leur place eux
est le remède à toutes les occasions
peuple à la blanquette du dimanche
la blanquette d'anniversaire comme la
blanquette de noël la blanquette du
petit déj
bon j'ai tenté un steak frites mais là
on n'est pas sur un succès succès attend
les papas être quand même une place
primordiale c'est quand même souvent à
eux que revient le rôle de nous
apprendre l'origine de la vie
si nicolas tu commences avec grand
maintenant et en tant que père c'est mon
rôle de t'expliquer un petit peu bas
comment on fait les bébés fall de vis
très simple c'est un pastiche grogne qui
va dans le nid de maman cigognes et là
il commence un petit peu à faire des
bisous ah bon [ __ ] j'étais persuadé
que ça se passait comme dans la
catégorie gang bang sur aix hamster ah
ouais ouais c'est aussi une autre façon
de le faire mais ils sont très très
belles ces cigognes écouter n'importe
quoi tu confies ton ordinateur
et je te confie son chargeur aussi et
c'est quoi ton mot de passe c'est je
suis à choisir je suis à chaud est mort
ok je suis quoi je suis un bon mon père
quand même parle de son enfance dans le
milieu ouvrier du nord de la france
chine a besoin d'avoir une vie de prince
comparé à lui c'est le culpabiliser de
ouf
tu saison
quand j'avais ton âge à la maison seul
avec de l'eau glacée on avait une pomme
de terre pour tenir tout l'hiver et ne
jouais c'était simplement les phalanges
de nos amis morts à la guerre
j'ai vraiment eu une enfance facile à
côté de toi papa était qu un salut tôt
tu as eu une enfance carrément cool ça
va je râle roman c'est un peu ma vie
c'est bon mais de quelques on parle
compte moi quand j'avais 4 ans on m'a
mis à la demie et en plus on se fait
battre avec des fluence bref pour
conclure ça peut paraître évident mais
si j'avais trop de le redire quant à la
chance d'avoir un père présent à tes
côtés parfois en profiter passer du
temps avec lui
plus on sait que tulle m écoutez
attentivement s'il est apte à prendre
parce que et des choses de la vie que tu
pourras prendre que par lui je me
souviens
donc j'ai hâte au même jeu
i télé j'ai rencontré maman depuis peu
de temps
on s'adresse était fantastique
fou amoureux
et c'est comme ça que maman et moi on a
conçu dans un camping sur un matelas
gonflable
je vais faire un tour et réfléchir un
peu ma vie abonnez-vous à la chaîne des
monts tunis normale très des mines et
aux coutumes des gouttes franchement tu
es pas de dînette un jour du week-end ok
les mecs vous avez gagné
c'est quoi je vais prendre ma douche et
j'arrive y est bon les vidéos c'est cool
mais c'est quand même beaucoup mieux en
vrai alors prenez vos places pour voir
mon spectacle norman sur scène que je
joue bientôt par exemple à orléans à
angers à marseille à nice et dans pleins
pleins d'autres villes a très vite
[Musique]